right now ai is from a geopolitical
point of view a a tool in the Armory or
toolkit of two superpowers and nobody
else because only the United States and
China has companies capable of uh this
kind of innovation and as I mentioned
earlier it's probably best to think of a
cold war framework and to see this as
the latest
feature of the arms race that
characterizes cold Wars
the narcissism of small differences
propels much more conflict than
civilizations clash and part of the
point of a cold war is that it's not
really a clash a cold war is a piece
that is no peace that was George
Orwell's term that's what the US and
China currently have